if a person is suffering from
asthma um can he or she utilize using
treatments Like Oxygen vaporizers and
other oral
tablets as far as a person who's taking
treatment for asema there are different
types of treatment taken for person
suffering from asema it can be puffers
it can be oxygen it can be
vaporizers it can be
tablets and capsules in short when a
person uses a puffer the gas goes by
force into the lungs expands the lung
and in no way does it break the fast
because it's mere gas going into the
lungs it's not a food it doesn't go into
the stomach and it's only gas so it does
not break the fast if a person uses a
puffer as far as oxygen is concerned
that too it's inhaled goes in the lungs
comes out so oxygen per also does not
break the fast does not inv validate the
fast but as far as vaporizers are
concerned vaporizers can be of different
types can be in form of liquid can be
gracious form of
particles and this medicine is put in a
container and once the button is pressed
the pressure which comes and by pressure
it enters into the lungs and it may be
through a nozzle can be through a mask
but when it enters the lungs there are
high chance say that there are particles
which may even go into the stomach so
that's the reason most of the scholars
say that vaporizes as a treatment for AA
it will break the
fast as far as capsules are concerned
the capsules they contain the medicine
in the form of a powder it has a
covering once you put in the container
and when the pressure is released it
comes out by force but this too can
enter the stomach the particles so even
using these capsules as the treat of Asa
it will surely break the fast so only
two things which are permitted as far as
a person suffering from the dis of Asa
is puffers and oxygen this will not
break the fast